récemment le moteur d'un boeing 777
exploser en plein vol
heureusement il n'y a pas une victime
mais imaginons un matériau qui s'inspire
des toiles d'araignées pour contenir ce
type d'explosion
un ingénieur québécois y travaillent
depuis des millions d'années
l'araignée peaufine sa technique de
chasse sa toile est à la fois légère et
capable d'encaisser un choc violent
sans échapper la proie un exploit qui a
inspiré l'ingénieur fredrik gosselet à
la base on a beaucoup d'applications en
génie où on cherche à faire la même
chose que l'araignée c'est-à-dire
attrapé quelque chose au vol la toile
d'araignée et fait deux choses donc
d'une part avoir intercepté l'insecte
qui vient frapper dedans mais d'autre
part à vau aussi dissipé beaucoup
d'énergie parce qu'on veut pas que la
toile d'araignée soit comme un
trampoline puisqu'elle car renvoi
l'insecte de l'autre côté il faut que
toute l'énergie l'impact soit absorbée
est dissipée par la structure
le secret est dans la structure même de
la soie d'araignée
l'idée c'est d'obtenir même performance
avec un plastique
[Musique]
pour y arriver frédéric gosselin et son
équipe se servent d'une imprimante 3d
mais de la mauvaise façon en la forçant
à injecter trop plastique trouver
typiquement ce qu'on cherche à faire
l'impasse en 3d c'est vraiment contrôler
plus le plus précisément possible la
déposition du matériau nous ce qu'on
espère c'est le contraire c convient
céder à cette instabilité la aux
filaments qui dansait dans tous les sens
ça nous permet de faire des formes
complexes qui serait très difficile à
coder puis à fabriquer
[Musique]
ses formes ce sont des filaments de
plastique qui s'entortille à chaque
boucle le fils se soudent légèrement sur
lui-même ce sont les liens sacrificielle
un des mécanismes qui vont dissiper
l'énergie lors d'un impact la fibre doit
s'étirer le lien sacrificielle se brise
c'est là qu'entre en action un deuxième
mécanisme la longueur cacher le segment
de fibres qui n'avaient pas encore été
exposées se met à résister à l'étirement
un peu comme ressemble
qu'on a démontré en fait c'est que la
majeure partie de l'énergie sert en fait
à venir des formes et la boucle pour la
rendre droite lorsqu'on vient appliquer
le chargement donc c'est pas tant le
lien sacrificielle qui est important
dans nos fibres vraiment la longueur
cache donc c'est l'addition d'un grand
nombre de petites boucles qu'il faut
venir redresser puis et tirer toutes
ensemble et c'est là où votent toute
l'énergie
ces fibres forment une sorte de treillis
qui est ensuite intégré dans une matrice
de plastique pour former une pellicule
transparente
pour vérifier ses performances chaque
échantillon est solidement fixés
en place au dessus un impacteur de plus
deux demi kilo et ont filmé la suite
avec une caméra à haute vitesse
en test tour à tour plastique uniforme
puis un treillis droit plus traditionnel
et celui développé par l'équipe
il réussi à dissiper plus de 95 % de
l'énergie et surtout à retenir
l'impacteur
[Musique]
lorsqu'on venait impact et une feuille
de polymère une forme les dommages
étaient très circonscrits c'est à dire
que on a vraiment une fissure circulaire
autour de la forme de l'impact heures
puis l'impact heures passées au travers
de notre matériau avec notre composé on
est cette idée là de longues heures
cachées qui doit être déployé des liens
sacrificielle qui doivent être brisé on
est les fibres qui vont avoir tendance à
vouloir briser sortir de la matrice donc
on a vraiment le dommage qui va être
distribué partout dans le matériau donc
c'est comme ça que notre matériau réussi
à à venir disputer toute l'énergie de
l'impasse à terme cette pellicule pour
être intégré à des vitres pare balles ou
encore pour boîtiers qui entoure les
moteurs d'avion parce qu'il arrive qu'un
moteur explose en plein vol comme à
denver au colorado en février il faut
donc tester les moteurs pour y résister
ici à plein régime ont fait décrocher
une partie des lices quand le moteur
explose le boîtier nous retenir tous les
débris
[Musique]
ça va se faire avec une grande énergie
de le moteur qui tourne à pleine vitesse
et donc ses critiques et donc c'est même
très normé il faut s'assurer qu'aucune
pièce va transpercer la carlingue ou une
aile de l'avion
donc ça prend un matériau qui à la fois
très tenace pour dissiper toute
l'énergie de cette explosion là mais
aussi un matériau qui est très léger
parce que ça vole avec l'avion privé en
miniaturisant les boucles on pouvait les
imprimer directement à l'intérieur des
boîtiers de moteurs d'avion pour
remplacer les matériaux utilisés en ce
moment mais l'objectif de frédéric
gosselin s'est d'abord d'explorer de
nouvelles approches pour créer les
matériaux de demain
c'est un changement de philosophie c'est
à dire que en ingénierie on a tendance à
vouloir faire les choses pour pas de
saint-brice mes moments où ça brise mais
ça brise de façon catastrophique tout
s'effondre tout s'écroule tout brise en
éclats nous ce qu'on a fait en fait
c'est on essaie planifié comment nos
matériaux à les briser donc on l'a conçu
pour qui se brise d'une certaine façon
en distribuant l'énergie et puis en
finissant son travail c'est d'attraper
l'impacteur jusqu'à la
[Musique]